The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR RABBAH: OK, so today's
the last lecture day
we're going to talk about
the raw architecture.
This is a processor that was
built here at MIT and
essentially trailblazed a lot
of the research in terms of
parallel architectures for
multicores, compilation for
multicores, programming
language and so on.
So you've heard some things
about RAW and the
parallelizing technology
in terms of StreamIt.
So we're going to cover some of
that again here today just
briefly and give you little
bit more insight into what
went into the design of
the raw architecture.
So these are RAW chips
they were delivered
in October of 2002.
Each one of these has
16 processors on it.
I'm going to show you sort of
a diagram on the next slide.
It's really a tiled
microprocessor.
We'll get into what that means
and how it actually--
what does a tiled microprocessor
give you that
makes it an attractive
design point in the
architecture space?
Each of the raw tiles-- you can
sort of see the outline
here sort of replicates--
is four millimeters.
It's four millimeters square.
It's a single-issue
8-stage pipeline.
It has local memory, so
there's a 32K cache.
And the unique aspect of the raw
processor is that is has a
lot of on-chip networks that you
could use to orchestrate
communication between
processors.
So there's two operand
networks.
I'm going to get into
what that means and
what they used for.
But these eventually allow
you to do point-to-point
communication between tiles
with very low latency.
And then there's a network that
essentially allows you to
handle cache misses and input
and output and one for message
passings, a more dynamic style
of messaging, something
similar to what you're
accustomed to at the cell, for
example, in DMA transfers.
This was built in 180
nanometer ASIC
technology by IBM.
It's got 100 million
transistors.
It was designed here by
MIT grad students.
It's got something like
a million gates on it.
Three to four years of
development time.
And what was really interesting
here is that this
was-- because of the tiled
nature of the architecture,
you could just design one tile
and then once you have one
tile, you essentially just plop
down more and more and
more of them.
And so you have one, you scale
it out to 16 tiles.
And the design sort of came back
without any bugs when the
first chip was delivered.
The core frequency was expected
to run at 425--
I think lower than
425 megahertz.
AUDIENCE: Designed for 250?
PROFESSOR RABBAH: 250 megahertz
and came back and it
ran 425 megahertz.
And it's been clocked as high as
500 megahertz at 2.2 volts.
The chip isn't really designed
for low power but the tile
abstraction is really nice for
power consumption because if
you're not using tiles
you can essentially
just shut them down.
So it'll allow you to sort of
have power efficient design
just by nature of the
architecture.
But when you're using all the
tiles, all the memories, all
the networks, in a non-optimized
design, you
consume about 18
watts of power.
So how do you use this
tiled processor?
So here's one particular
example.
The nice thing about tile
architecture is that you can
let applications consume as
many tiles as they need.
If you have an application with
a lot parallelism then
you give it a lot of tiles.
If you have an application that
doesn't need a lot of
parallelism then you don't
give it a lot of tiles.
So it allows you to really
exploit the mapping of your
application down to the
architecture and gives you
ASIC-like behavior-- application
specific
processing technology.
So one example is you have
some video that you're
recording and you want to encode
it and stream it across
the web or display it on your
monitor or whatever else.
So you can have some logic
that you map down.
If your chips are here, you
do some computation.
You have memories sprinkled
across the tile that you're
going to use for local store.
So you can parallelize, for
example, the motion estimation
for encoding the temporal
redundancy in a video stream.
You can have another application
completely
independent running on other
part of the chip.
So here's an application that's
using four different
tiles and it's really
isolated.
It doesn't affect what's going
on in these tiles.
You can have another application
that's running
something like MPI where
you're doing dynamic
messaging, and httpd server
and this tile is maybe not
used so it's just sleeping
or it's idle.
You can have memories
connected off
the chip, I/O devices.
So it's really interesting in
the sense that probably the
most interesting aspect of it is
you just allow the tiles to
sort of be used as your
fundamental resource.
And you can scale
them up as your
application parallelism scales.
This is a picture of the raw
board-- the raw motherboard.
Actually you see it in the Stata
Center in the Raw Lab.
This is the raw chip.
A lot of the peripheral
device, firmware and
interconnect for dealing with a
lot of devices off the chip
are implemented in
these FPGAs, so
these are Xilinx chips.
There's DRAM.
You have connection to a
PCI card, USB stick.
Network interface so you can
actually log into this machine
and use it.
And there's a real compiler.
It can run real applications
on it.
There's actually a bigger chip
that we built where we take
four of these raw chips and
sort of scale them up.
So rather than having 16 tiles
on your motherboard, you can
have four raw chips.
That gives you 64 tiles.
You can scale this up to a
thousand tiles or so on.
Just because of the tile
nature, everything is
symmetric, homogeneous, so
you can really scale
it up really big.
So what is the performance
of raw?
So looking at the overall
application performance, so
we've done a lot of
benchmarking.
So these are numbers from a
paper that was published in
2004, where we took a lot of
applications-- some are
well-known and used in standard
benchmark suites--
and compiled them for raw using
various raw compiler
that we built in-house.
And we've compared them
against the Pentium 3.
So the Pentium 3 is sort of
a unique comparison point
because it sort of matches raw
in terms of the technology
that was used to fabricate
the two.
And what you're seeing here,
this is a lock scale.
The speedup of the application
running on raw compared to the
application running on a P3.
So the higher you get, the
better the performance is.
So these applications are sort
of grouped into a few classes.
So the first class is what
we call ILP applications.
So these are applications that
have essentially instruction
level parallelism.
I'm going to talk a little
bit more about and
sort of explain it.
But you've seen this early
on in the lecture--
in some of Saman's lectures.
So here you're trying to exploit
inherent instruction
level parallelism in
the applications.
And if you have lots of ILP then
you map it to a lot of
tiles and you can get
parallelism that way and you
get better performance.
These applications here-- what
we call the streaming
applications.
So you saw some of these in the
StreamIt lecture and the
StreamIt parallelizer
compiler.
Some of those numbers were
generated on a raw-like
architecture.
And then you have the server
or sort of more traditional
applications that you expect
to run in a server style or
throughput-oriented.
And then finally you have
bit-level applications.
So doing things at the very
lowest level of computation
where you're doing a lot
of bit manipulation.
So what's interesting here to
note is that as you get into
more applications that have a
lot of inherent parallelism in
them, where you want
explicit--
where you can extract a lot of
parallelism because of the
explicit nature of the
applications--
you can really map those
really well through the
architecture.
And because of the communication
nature--
because of communication
capabilities of the
architecture, being able to
stream data from one tile to
another really fast, you can
get really high on-chip
bandwidth and that gives you
really high performance,
especially for these kinds
of applications.
There are other applications
that we've done.
Some of the students have worked
on in the raw group.
So an MPEG-2 encoder where
you're essentially trying to
do real-time encoding of a
video screen at different
resolutions.
So 350 by 240 or 720 by 480
where you're compiling down to
a number of tiles.
One, 4, 8 sixteen, 16--
1 and 16 are somehow missing,
I'm not sure why.
And what you're looking
for here?
Sort of scalability
of algorithm.
As you add more tiles, are
you getting more and more
performance or are you getting
better and better throughput?
So you could encode more frames
per second for example.
So if you're doing HDTV, it's
1080p, then you really want to
sort of get--
there's a lot of compute
power that you need.
And so as you add more frames,
maybe you can get to sort of
the throughput that
you need for HDTV.
So this is something that might
be interesting for some
of your projects as well.
And we've talked about
this before.
On the cell, as you're using
more and more SPEs, can you
accelerate the performance
of your application?
Can you sort of show
that if you're
doing some visual aspect?
And you can sort of
demonstrate it.
So there's a demo that is set
up and in the lab where you
can sort of crank up number of
tiles that you're using and
you get better performance
from the MPEG encoder.
And just looking at number of
frames per second that you can
get, with 64 tiles-- so the raw
chip is 16 tiles, but you
can scale it up by having
more chips--
so you can get about
51 frames.
These numbers have been
improved and there are
different ways of optimizing
these performances.
At 352 by 4 240, the estimated
data rate-- estimated
throughput--
of 160 frames per second
almost. So this
is really high bandwidth.
Another interesting thing that
we've done with the raw chip
is taking a look at graphics
pipelines and looking at is
there anything we can do to
exploit the inherent tiled
architecture of the raw chip.
So here's a screenshot from
Counterstrike and a simplified
graphics pipeline where you have
some input to the screen
you want to render.
You do some vertex shading.
So these are triangles that you
want to figure out what
colors to make--
what colors to paint them.
The triangle's set up
for pixel stage.
And in this screen you'll notice
that there are two
different things that
you're rendering.
There's essentially this part of
the screen which has a lot
of triangles that span
a relatively
not-so-complex image.
And then you have these guys
here that have fewer triangle
span a smaller region
of the frame.
And what you might want to do
is allocate more computer
power to the pixel stage and
less compute power to the
vertex stage.
So that's analogous to saying,
I want more tiles for one
stage of the pipeline and
fewer tiles for another.
Or maybe I want to be able to
dynamically change how many
tiles I'm allocating
at different
stages of the pipeline.
So that as your screens that
you're rendering change in
terms of their complexity, you
can maintain the good visual
illusions transparently without
compromising the
utilization of the chip.
So some demos that were
done with the
graphics group it at MIT--
Fredo Durand's group--
phong shading.
You have 132 vertices
with 1 light source.
So this is what you're
trying to shade.
You have a lot of
regions black.
So if you're looking at a
fixed pipeline where the
vertex shader is taking
six tiles-- this is
on a 64-tile chip--
the rasterizer is taking 15
tiles, the pixel processor has
15 tiles, the alpha buffer
operations has 15 tiles, then
you might not get the best
utilization because for that
entire region that you're
rendering where it's black
there's nothing really
interesting happening there.
You want to shift those tiles
to another processor, to
another stage of pipeline.
Or, if you can't really utilize
them, then you're just
wasting power, wasting energy,
and so you might just want to
shut them and not
use them at all.
So with a fixed pipeline
versus a reconfigurable
pipeline where I can change the
number of tiles allocated
to different stages of the
pipeline, I can get better
utilization.
And, in some cases, better
performance.
So here, fuller bars,
and you're
finishing faster in time.
So this is indicative also
of what's going on in the
graphics industry.
So the graphics card
used to be very--
well, it had fixed resources
allocated to different stage,
which is essentially what we're
trying model in this
part of the experiment, where
more and more now you have
unified shaders that you can use
for the pixel shading and
the vertex shading.
So you're getting into more of
that programmable aspect.
Precisely because you want to
be able to do this kind of
load balancing and exploit
dynamisms that you see in
different things that you're
trying to render.
Another example:
shadow volumes.
You have 4 triangles,
one light source.
And this was rendered
in three passes.
So pass 1, pass 2, pass 3, would
essentially take the
same amount of time because
you're doing the same
computation map to a fixed
number of resources.
But if I can change the number
of resources that I need for
different passes-- so the
rasterizer, for example, and
the alpha buffer operations,
is really where you
need a lot of power.
So if you go from 15 tiles for
each to 20 tiles for each, you
get better execution time
because you were able to
exploit parallelism or match
parallelism better to the
application.
And so you get 40%
percent faster in
this particular case.
And another interesting
application: this is the
largest in the world
microphone array.
It's actually in the Guinness
Book of Records.
It was build in the lab.
And what it essentially has--
each of these little boards
has two microphones on it.
And so what you can
use this for is
eavesdropping for example.
Or you can carry this
around if you want.
Pack it in the car and
do some spying.
But somewhat more interesting
demos that were done with this
in smaller scales was that in a
noisy room, for example, if
you want the sort of hone in.
Let's say everybody here was
speaking, but for the camera
they want to record
only my voice.
They can have a microphone array
in the back that focuses
on just my voice.
And the way it's done is you can
measure the distance from
the time it takes for the sound
wave to reach each of
these different microphones
and you can focus in on a
particular source of noise
and be able to
just highlight that.
So there's this demo where's
it's a noisy room--
I probably should have had these
in here in retrospect--
there's a noisy room, lots of
people are talking, then you
turn on the microphone array
and you can hear that one
particular source and
it's a lot clearer.
You can also have applications
where you're tracking a person
in a room with videos as
well, so you can sort
of follow him around.
So it's a very interesting
application.
An now I regret not having
the video demo in here.
Actually, should I do it?
It's on the Web.
OK.
So a case study using
the beamformer.
So what's being done in the
microphone array is you're
doing beamforming.
So you're trying to figure out
what are the different beams
that are reaching
the microphone.
You want to be able to
amplify one of them.
So looking at the application
written natively in C running
on a 1 gigahertz Pentium
, what is the operation
throughput?
So you're getting about
240 MegaFLOPS.
And if you go down
to an optimized--
same code but running on single
tile raw chip, you get
about 19 MegaFLOPS.
So a not very good
performance.
But here, what you really want
to do, is you have al lot of
parallelism.
Because each of those beams
that's reaching individual
microphones can be
done in parallel.
So you have a lot of
parallelism in that
application.
So taking the C program,
reimplementing it in StreamIt
that you've seen in previous
lectures, and not really
optimizing it in terms
of doing a lot of the
optimizations you saw in the
parallelizing compiler talk,
you get about 640 MegaFLOPS.
So already you're beating the C
program running on a pretty
fast superscalar machine.
And if you really optimize the
StreamIt code in terms of
doing the fission and fusion,
increasing the parallelism,
doing better load balancing
automatically, you can get up
to 1.4 GigaFLOPS.
So really good performance and
really matching the inherent
parallelism to the
architecture.
So it was just a big overview of
the raw chip and what we've
done with it in lab.
There's more in here than
I've talked about.
But what I'm going to do next
is give you some insights as
to what is the design philosophy
that went into raw
architecture, why was it
designed the way it was.
And then I'm going to talk a
little bit about the raw
parallelizing compiler.
And while the StreamIt language
and compiler also has
a back end for the raw
architecture, we've sort of
seen that in previous lectures
so I'm not going to
talk about that here.
So I'm just going to focus
on the first two bullets.
And a few years ago when the
project got started, sort of
the insight in the wide issue
processors and the design
philosophy that was being
followed in industry for
building wider superscalars,
faster superscalars, was
really going to come to a halt
largely because you have
scalability issues.
So if you look at sort of a
simplified illustration of a
wide issue microprocessor, you
have your program counter such
as instructions.
Goes into some control logic.
Control logic is then
going to run.
You're going to read
some variables from
the register file.
You'll have a big crossbar in
the middle that routes to
operands like ALUs.
Yell And then you operate on
those and you have to send it
back to the register file.
Plus you have this really big
problem with the network.
So if you're doing some
computation--
sorry, I rearranged
these slides.
So what you have if you have n
ALUs, then the complexity of
your crossbar increases as
n squared, because you
essentially have to
have everybody
talking to each other.
And in terms of the number of
wires that you need out of the
register file to support
everybody being able to sort
of talk to anybody else very
efficiently, the number of
ports, the number of wires
increases n cubed.
So that's a problem because
you can't clock all those
wires fast enough.
The frequency becomes
sort of limited.
It grows even less
than linearly.
And this is a problem because
operational routing-- operand
routing, is global.
So if I have- I'm doing some
operations and it's an add,
the results of this add is fed
to another operation to shift,
and these are going to execute
on two different ALUs.
So what's going to happen?
I do the add operation.
It's going to produce
a result.
But there's no direct path for
this ALU to send this result
to this ALU.
So instead what has happened is
the operand has to travel
all the way back around through
the crossbar and then
back to this ALU.
So that's really just going to
take a long time and not
necessarily very efficient.
And if you're doing this for a
lot of ALU operations, you
have a lot of parallelism in
your application level,
instructional level parallelism,
and that's just
creating a lot of
communication.
But you're not really exploiting
the locality of the
computation.
If 2 instructions are really
close together, you want to be
able to just have a
point-to-point path, for
example, or a shorter path that
allows you to exploit
where was instructions
are in space.
And so this was the driving
insight for the architecture
in that you want to make
operand routing local.
So an idea is to essentially
exploit this locality by
distributing the ALUs.
And rather than having that
massive crossbar, what you
want to do is have an on-chip
mesh network.
So rather than have one big
crossbar, you have lots of
smaller ones.
So these become switch
processors.
So I can put value from this
ALU here and then have that
value routed to any other ALU.
Maybe that just cost me more in
terms of instructions that
says where this operand
is going.
We'll get into that.
But here, what this allows
me to do is exploit
that locality better.
Same instruction chain, I can
put the first operation on one
ALU, I can put the other
operation on the second ALU.
And here, rather than putting
it for example here, which
would send the operand really
far across chip, what I want
to do is recognize that there's
a producer/consumer
relationship here.
I want to exploit that locality
and have them close
in spaces so that the routes
remain fairly short.
You know what I can also do is
sort of pipeline this network
so that I can have the hardware
essential match
computation flow.
If one ALU is producing a lot
of results at a lot faster
rate than for example this
instruction can consume them,
then the hardware can take care
of, for example, blocking
or stalling the producing
processor so it doesn't get
too far ahead.
It gives you a nature mechanism
for regulating the
flow data on the chip.
Well, this is better than what
we saw before because with the
crossbar you're not really
getting any scalability in
terms of your latency transport
operands from one
ALU to another.
Whereas with on-chip network,
if you've taken routing
classes, you know that there
exists an algorithm that sort
of allows it to route things at
least the square root of n,
where n is the number of things
that are communicating
in your network.
But if you're doing locality
driven placement then it's
essentially costing time.
And in a raw chip, it's
in fact three cycles.
So you can send one operand from
one tile to another in
three cycles.
And we'll get into how that
number comes about.
So this is much better.
But what it does
is increase the
complexity on the compiler.
It says, this is my computation,
how do you map it
efficiently so that things are
clustered in space well so
that I don't have these really
long routes for communication?
But then we can look at what
else can we distribute.
Well, we have the
register file.
We can distribute that
across all the ALUs.
And that essentially decreases
that n cubed relationships
between ALUs and register file
ports to something that's a
lot more tractable.
Where it's one small
register per ALU.
And this is better in terms of
scalability, but we haven't
solved the entire problem in
that we still have one global
program counter, we have one
global instruction fetch unit,
one global control unified
load/store queue for
communicating with memory.
And those all have scalability
problems. So whereas we fixed
the problem with
the crossbar--
that becomes more scalable--
we haven't really fix the
problems with the others.
So what's the natural
solution to do here?
Well, we'll just distribute
everything else.
And so you start off with each
ALU here now having it's own
program counter, its own
instruction cache, it's own
data cache.
And it has its register file ALU
and everybody-- that same
sort of design pattern
is repeated for each
one of those ALUs.
So now it looks like it's
a lot scalable.
I don't have any global wires.
There's no global centralized
data structure.
And all of that means I
can do things more--
I can do things faster
and more efficiently.
And what you start seeing here
is this sort of tile processor
coming about all.
So each one of those things
was exactly the same.
And what was done in the raw
processor is that none of
those tiles was longer than
you can communicate in one
clock cycle.
So this solved essentially a
wire delay problem as well.
So if this is the distance
that a wire--
that a signal can travel
in one clock
cycle, the tile is smaller.
It can fit within this circle.
So that means that you're
guaranteed--
you have better scalability
problems. You're solving the
issues that people are facing
with wire delay.
And in terms of the tile
processor abstraction, Michael
Taylor was is a PhD student in
the raw group, his thesis sort
of identified the tile processor
approach and this
aspect of the tile processor
approach that makes it more
attractive, the SON.
Which is the scalar
operand network.
And the next two slides, the
next part of the lecture, is
going to really focus
on what that means.
He argues why the tile
processor approach is scalable.
And it's scalable for the same
reasons as multicores.
You just add more and more
cores on a chip.
But the intrinsic difference
between the multicore that you
see today and the raw
architecture is the scalar
operand network.
So I'm going to ask you
questions about
this in a few slides.
But really what you're getting
here is the ability to
communicate from one processor
to another very efficiently.
And the way you do this on raw
is you have your instruction
fetch d code, register file
read stage, WALU--
your competition pipeline.
But part of the registers-- the
new register file-- so 24
through 27 are network mapped.
So what that means is, if
I write-- if one of the
operations that I have in my
computation has a destination
register that's 24, 25, 26 or
27, that value automatically
get sent to the output
network.
And if I have a value--
if one of my source operands is
registered at 24, 25, 26 or
27, implicitly that means get
that value off the network.
And so I can have add 25--
added to register 25-- so this
is one of the network map
ports, sum two operands.
So this is a picture
of the raw chip.
This is one tile.
This is the other tile.
So you can sort of see the
computation and the network
switch processor here.
So the operand flows into the
network and then gets
transported across from
one tile to the other.
And then gets injected
into the other
tiles compute networks.
And here this instruction has
sort a source operand that
that's register map operand.
So it knows where to
get its value from.
And then you can do
the computation.
An interesting aspect here
is that while you've seen
instructions like this, just
normal instructions, here you
also have explicit routing
instructions that are executed
on the switch processor.
So the switch processor here
says take the value that's
coming from my processor and
send it east. So each
processor can send values east,
west, north or south.
So it can go to the tile above
it, the tile below it, the
tile to the left of it or
tile to the right of it.
And so sending it east sends
it along this wire here.
And then this particular switch
processor says get a
value from the west port and
send it to my processor.
Now you could have had here,
this process could say, this
value is not for me, so I want
to just pass through to some
other processor.
So you can pass it from the west
port to the south port or
to the north port or just pass
it through laterally to the
other east port.
So it just allows you to
essentially just have an
on-chip network and not
operand-- you can imagine
having an operand that has a
data packet and header that's
says, I'm going to tile 10
and the switches know
which way to send it.
But the interesting aspect
here is that the compiler
actually orchestrates the
communication, so you don't
need that extra header that
says, I'm going to tile 10.
You just have to generate a
schedule of how to write that
data through.
So we'll get into what that
means for the compiler in
terms of that added
complexity.
So communication on multicores
is expensive for
the following reasons.
And this is really sort of going
contrast or going to put
the scalar operand network
into slightly more
perspective.
But first, so how do you
communicate between multicores
on the cell?
You have the DMA transfers
from one SPE to another.
You can't really ship an
operand single value.
So if I write the value x, and
I want to send x from one SPE
to another, I can't really do
that very efficiently, right?
So this is essentially the
contrasting thing between
multicore processors that
largely exist today and the
raw processor.
So I've shown you an empirical--
a quantitative--
an analytical model for
communication costs before in
earlier slides.
This is an illustration
of that concept.
So if I have a processor that's
talking to another,
that value has to travel
across some network and
there's some transport costs
associated with that.
But there's also some
added complexities.
So there were lots of terms,
if you remember, in that
really big equation
I've shown before.
You have some overhead in terms
of packaging the data.
And you have some overhead in
terms of unpacking the data.
So what does that look?
Well, there are two components
we're going to break this down
to: the send occupancy
and send latency.
And I'm going to talk
about each of those.
And similarly on the receive
side, you have the receive
latency and the receive
occupancy.
So bear in mind, this lifetime
of a message essentially has
to flow through these
five components.
It has to go through the
occupancy stage, then there's
the send latency, transport,
receive latency and receive
occupancy before you can
actually use it to compute on.
So what are some things
that you do here?
Well, it's things that you've
done on cell for getting VME
transfers to work.
You have to figure who the
destination is, what is the
value, maybe you have an idea
associated with it, a tag,
things of that sort.
And you have to essentially
inject that
message into the network.
So there's some latency
associated with that.
Maybe your--
on cell you have a DMA engine
which essentially hides this
latency for you.
Because you can essentially just
send the message to the
DMA, right into its queue.
And you can especially forget
about it unless it stalls
because the DMA list is full.
On the receive side, you sort
of have a similar thing.
You have to get the network to
inject that value into the
processor and then you have to
depackage it, demultiplex it
and put it into some form that
you can actually use to
operate on it.
So this 5-tuple is gives us a
way of sort of characterizing
communication patterns on
different architectures.
So I can contrast, for example,
raw versus the
traditional microprocessor.
So this is a traditional
superscalar.
A traditional superscalar
essentially has all the
sophisticated circuitry that
allows you to essentially
bypass network.
You can have an operand directly
flowing to another
ALU through all the n squared
wires in the crossbar.
And a lot of dynamic scheduling
is going on.
So it really has no occupancy,
latency, you're not really
doing any packaging
of the operands.
Your transport cost is
essentially completely hidden.
You have no complexity
on the receive side.
So it's really efficient.
So this is essentially what you
want to get to go: this
kind of 5-tuple.
But as we saw before, it's
really not scalable because
the wire complexity woes--
whether it's n squared or n
cubed, that's not good
from an energy
efficient point of view.
Scalable multiprocessors--
these are on-chip
multiprocessors more
indicative of things that you
have today-- have this kind of
5-tuple where you have about
16 cycles just to get a
message out, know roughly
3 cycles are so
to transport message.
So maybe this is being done
through a shared cache.
Which is how a lot of
architecture communicates
between processors today.
And you have to sort of
demultiplex the message on the
receive side.
So that adds some latency.
In raw, because you have these
net memory map registers on
the input side and the output
side, you really can knock
down the complexity from the
send side in terms of the
occupancy and latency to zero.
And you just write the values
to the register.
And it looks like a normal
register, right?
But it just magically appears
on the network.
And then from one tile to
another, it's one cycle to
ship the value across that one
link from one switch processor
to the other, as long as
it's a near neighbor.
And then two cycles to
inject the network
into the tile processor.
And then you're ready
to use it.
So in this space, where would
you put cell is the question?
Anybody have any ideas?
What would the communication
panel look like on cell?
So you have to do explicit
sends and receives.
So let's look at this.
So can we get rid of this
stage on cell which is
essentially saying
packaging up my
message, is it's no, right?
Because you have to essentially
say where that DMA
transfer is going to go to--
which region of memory?
So you're buildings these
control blocks.
And then the send latency here
is roughly zero, because you
have the DMA processor which
allows that kind of
concurrency between
communication and computation,
so you can hide essentially that
part of the transport--
that part of communication
costs.
Your transport costs here, you
have this really massive
bandwidth, this really
high bandwidth
interconnect on the chip.
So this makes it reasonably
fast, but
it's still a few cycles.
There's no near neighbor?
Yeah, a hundred cycles to go
near neighbor communication.
Because you're still--
you don't have that fast
mechanism of being able to
send things points to point.
You're putting things on the
bus and there's some
complexity there.
On the receive, you have the
same kind of complexity that
you had on the send side.
You have to know that the
message is coming, that can be
done in different ways.
And then you have to take that
message and write it into your
local store.
Which also adds some overhead in
terms of the communication
cost. So the cell would probably
be somewhere up here,
I would imagine.
I didn't have a chance
to get the numbers.
If I do, I'll update
the slide later on.
OK, so that's essentially a
brief insight into the raw--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Where did you get
the scalable processor?
PROFESSOR RABBAH: So these are
from Michael Taylor's thesis.
So I believe what he's done here
is just looked at some
existing microprocessor and
essentially benchmarked
communication latency from
one processor to another.
AUDIENCE: So this is like going
through the cache on the
[OBSCURED]?
PROFESSOR RABBAH: That's
in fact how you--
a lot of these multiprocessors
today have shared caches,
either L-1 and more
so now it's L-2.
So if you have--
L-1s are dedicated to different
processors.
But you still have to go the
memory to communicate.
So the raw parallelizing
compiler-- yeah?
Another question?
AUDIENCE: You might want to
postpone this question.
Two related questions:
so raw has--
I guess raw has pretty well
optimized nearest neighbor
communication.
But we know from, for example,
Red's Rule in heuristic and
intellectual engineering about
the number of wires needed for
a given area.
Is that in between--
as I recall, it's the minimum
for a good sized circuit is
proportional to the perimeter,
or roughly the
square root of the area.
And it ranges from there to--
not proportional to the area.
There's something in between.
Something with 3 in it.
Like to the 3/2 power
I think, perhaps.
No, something like 2/3rds,
something like--
yeah, 2/3rds power.
So the area to the 1/2 power or
area to the 2/3rds power.
So Red's Rule says the number
of wires you need is roughly
in that area.
And so that sort of
pushes that--
so the minimum you need is the
nearest communication.
And often you need
more than that.
We know from the FPGA experience
that nearest
neighbor communication
is not--
or, at least, it's good to
have move than nearest
neighbor, and that often long
wires followed across the
chip, in extremely high--
PROFESSOR RABBAH: So I'm going
to actually show you an
example where nearest neighbor
is good but you might also
want some global mechanism
for control
orchestration for example.
AUDIENCE: Not just for con--
not surely just for control
but for broadcast, for arbitrary
for the computation
to use, not just for
the chip to use.
Like why are you scaling out two
hops, four hops, fewer and
fewer wire--
PROFESSOR RABBAH: Yes, in fact
what I think is going to
happen is a lot of these chip
designs are going to be
heirarchical.
You have some really global
type communication at the
highest level.
And then as you get within each
one of the processors,
then you see things at the
lowest level, something that
looked like raw.
So you can build sort of a
hierarchy of communication
stages that allow you to sort
of solve that problem.
But all of that adds
complexity, right?
First you have to solve the
problem of how do you
parallelize for just a fixed
number of cores and then
figure out the communications.
Once we understand how to
do that well with a nice
programming model then you can
build heirarchically on that.
AUDIENCE: On the other hand, it
might make the compiler's
job easier because it's
not as constrained.
PROFESSOR RABBAH: It
might give you a
nice fall back rate.
It might save you in cases where
there are things that
are hard to do.
There are some issues
in the last two--
the second to the last
three slides.
We'll talk about an example of
where that might be the case.
AUDIENCE: Another question
which [OBSCURED]
so raw, I guess, being simpled
and tiled, I guess one of the
selling points I think was that
it really cuts down on
the engineering effort.
PROFESSOR RABBAH:
Oh, absolutely.
This was done a million gates
in-house for [OBSCURED]
AUDIENCE: So a company like
Intel has a ridiculous number
of engineers.
And to get a competitive edge,
they something they want to
apply more engineering to it.
And so the question is, where
might you apply more
engineering to try
to squeeze more--
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE: That's
the million dollar question
that everybody's looking at.
Because if somehow Intel thought
they could add more
and more engineering.
And then build this very complex
full-scale [OBSCURED]
But separate vessels.
And so I think there's still a
lot of things that is wrong.
Meaning it's [OBSCURED]
so at Intel basically
they will let you do
something like that.
They will put a lot of engineers
doing each of these
components, finding very few,
and they can get a lot more
performance, a lot less power
and stuff like that.
So depending on what you want,
science is not everything.
There are a lot of other
things [OBSCURED]
So while it makes it easier?
[OBSCURED]
And the key thing is, you start
something simple and as
you go on, you can add more
and more complexity.
Just, as there's more
things to do.
PROFESSOR RABBAH: Part of the
complexity might be going to--
not making all those
[OBSCURED].
OK, so raw pushes a lot of the
complexity into the compiler
in that the compiler now has
to do at least two things.
It has to distribute
the instructions.
You have a single program and
you have to figure out how to
parallelize it across
multiple cores.
But not only that, because you
have the scalar operand
network, you have to figure out
how the different cores
have to talk to each other.
So you have to essentially
generate schedule for the
switch processors as well.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about the
raw paralyzing compiler.
And this is different from
a StreamIT parallelizing
compiler which really talks
about a different program as
an input, using a different
language.
This is work again done here
at MIT by Walter Lee who
graduated two years ago.
We have a sequential program.
You inject it into raw C seed,
raw C compiler, and you get
fine-grained Orchestrated
Parallel execution.
And what the compiler does is
worry about data distribution
just like you have to do on cell
in terms of which memory
goes into which local store.
which competition
operates on--
the raw compiler has to worry
about which computation
operates on which data element
and can you put that data in
the right caches for each
of the different tiles.
Instruction distribution:
so the way this compiler
essentially get parallelism,
it's going to look at
instruction level parallelism
in your application.
And it's going to divide that up
among the different cores.
And then the last step is the
coordination of communication
in control flow.
So I'm just going
to briefly step
through each one of those.
So the data distribution really
has essentially trying
to solve the problem
of locality.
You have two instructions.
A load into r1 from some
address and then
you're adding r1.
You're incrementing
that value.
And you might write it
back for later on.
So where would you put these
two instructions?
So to exploit the locality, then
you want the data-- if
the data is here, then you want
these two instructions to
be on this tile.
If the data is here, then you
want these two instructions to
be on this file.
Because it doesn't help you to
have the data here and the
instructions here.
Because what do you have
to do in that case?
You have to send a message that
says, send me this data.
And then you have to wait for
it to come in and then you
have to operate on it.
And then maybe you have
to write it back.
So the compiler sort of
worries about the data
distribution.
It applies some data analysis.
A lot of a thing that you saw in
Saman's lecture on classic
parallelization technology.
Sort of figure out the
interdependencies and then
they can figure out how to split
up the data across the
different cores.
And there's some other work done
by other students in the
group that tried to address
this problem.
The instruction distribution is
perhaps as complicated and
interesting.
In here, what's going
on is-- let's say
you have a base block.
So you take your sequential
program.
You figure out what are the
different basic blocks of
computation that you have and
within the basic block you
have lots of instructions.
So each one of these green
boxes is a particular
instruction.
And what you're seeing-- these
arrows here that connect the
edges-- are operands that
you have to exchange.
So you might have--
this is an add instruction.
It requires a value
coming from here.
Multiply--
subtract instruction requires
values coming in from
different areas.
So how would you
distribute this
across a number of cores--
or across a number of tiles?
Any ideas here?
So you can look for, for
example, some chains that are
not interconnected.
So you can look for clusters
that you can use.
And say, OK, well I see no edges
here so maybe I can put
this on one tile.
And then maybe I can put some
of these instructions on
another tile.
Because sort of the
communication flow is local.
So maybe one strategy might
be, look for the longest
single chains so you can keep
the communication flow.
And then you apply and make and
algorithm, come up with a
number of clusters.
Something like that
does happen.
And keep in mind from the
lectures we talked about the
parallelizing compiler, you
have to worry about
parallelism versus
communication.
Some the more you distribute
things, the more communication
you have to get right.
So here we're showing--
what I'm showing is color
mapping from the original
instructions in the base block
to the same instructions, but
now each color essential
represents a different cluster
or essentially code that would
map a different thread.
So blue is one thread, yellow is
another, green is another,
red, purple, and so on.
But I have to worry about
communication between the
different colors because
they're essentially two
different threads.
They're going to run on two
different processors or two
different tiles.
So those arrows that are
highlighted in dark black are
communication edges.
They have to explicitly send
the operands around.
Right?
So then I might look
at the granularity.
What is my communication cost?
What is my computation cost?
And I want to worry about
load balancing.
As we saw, load balancing can
give you how it can better
make use of your architecture
and give you better
utilization, better
throughput.
So you might essentially say,
it doesn't-- it's not
worthwhile to have these running
on a different tile
because there's a lot of
communication going on.
So maybe I'd want to fuse
those together.
Keep the communication local.
And essentially eliminate
costly communication.
So there are different
heuristics that you can apply.
You can use that 5-tuple.
You can use heuristic space on
the 5-tuple to determine when
it's profitable to break things
up and when it's not.
And then you have to worry
about placement.
So you don't quite have this
on cell in that you create
these SPE threads and
they can run on any
SPE in the raw compiler.
You can actually exploit the
spacial characteristics of the
chip in the point-to-point
communication network to say,
I want to put these two threads
on tile 1 and tile 2,
where tile 1 and tile 2 are
adjacent to each other.
Because I have a well-defined
communication pattern that I'm
going to use.
And map to the communication
network on the chip to get
really fast, really
low latency.
So you can take each one of
these colors, place it on a
different tile.
And now you have these wires
that are going across these
tiles which essentially
represent communication.
But now the tile has to worry
about, oh, I have to
essentially send these
on fixed routes.
There's no arbitrary
communication mechanism.
So if there's data going from
this tile to this tile, it
actually has to be routed
through a network.
And that might mean getting
routing through somebody
else's tile.
So the next stage would be
communication coordination.
You have to figure out which
switch you need to go to and
what do you do to get that
operand to the right switch
which then gets it to
the right processor.
So here, I believe the heuristic
is to do dimension
order routing so you send along
the x-dimension and then
the y-dimension.
I might have those reversed.
I don't know.
And then finally, now you've
figured out your communication
patterns, you've figured out
your instructions, you do some
instructions scheduling.
And what you can do here,
because the communication
patterns are static, you've
split up the instructions so
you know when you need to ship
data around and how.
You can guarantee deadlock
freedom by carefully ordering
your send and receive pairs.
So what you see here, every time
you see an instruction
that needs to ship an operand
around, there's the equivalent
of a route instruction
that has route east,
west, north, south.
There's an equivalent route
instruction on the other
processors.
And that allows you to
essentially analyze code and
say, OK, I've laid these things
out carefully, I've
orchestrated my send and
receive pairs so I can
guarantee, for example, there
are no overlapping routes.
Or that there are no deadlocks
because one is trying to shift
the other while the other is
also trying to ship, and they
both block on the shared
network link.
And finally, you have the
code representation.
So this is where you package
things up into object files,
into essentially things
like threads.
And then you can compile
them and run them.
Now the question that was posed
earlier is, well there's
one thing we haven't talked
about and that's branching.
This is a sequential program,
it executes branches.
And now I have this loop that
I've split up across a number
of tiles, how do I know who's
going to do the branch?
And if one tile is doing
the branch, how does it
communicate with
everybody else?
Or if I'm going to repeat the
branch on every file, does
that mean I'm redoing
too much computation
on every other tile?
So control coordination is
actually quite an interesting
aspect of--
adds another interesting
aspect to the
parallelization for raw.
So what you have to
do is figure out--
there are two different
ways you can do it.
Because you have no mechanism
for a global message on raw,
you can't say, I've taken a
branch, everybody go to this
program counter.
You essentially have to send
either the branch result so
one tile can do the comparison,
it calculates the
condition, and then it has to
communicate x to each of the
different branches-- to each
of the different tiles.
Or every tiles has to
essentially just replicate the
control and redo the
computations.
So every tile figures out what
is the condition, what are the
conditions for the branch.
They redundantly do that
computation and then they can
all merge at the same time--
at different times.
So that gives you two ways
of doing the branching.
If each tile's doing its own
control flow calculation, then
they can essentially branch
at different times.
But if they're all going to
wait for the result to
compare, then it essentially
gives you points where you
have to synchronize.
Everybody's going to wait for
the result of the branch.
But the latency could
be different.
Because if I'm sending the
branch condition to one tile
versus another file, and if
one's closer than the other.
Then the branch that's closer to
me-- the tile that's closer
to me will take that branch
earlier in time.
So you get sort of the
effective of a global
asynchronous branching
in either case.
Does that make sense?
So, in summary, the raw
architecture is really a tile
microprocessor.
It incorporates the best
elements from superscalars in
terms of a really low latency
communication network between
tiles which really cuts down
on the communication costs.
And as we saw, and as probably
you've been learning,
communication is really
an expensive part of
parallelization on existing
multicore chips.
And it's also getting the
scalability of multicores in
terms of explicit parallelism
but also gives you implicit
parallelism because the networks
are pipelined and
they can give you
full control.
So you're trying to get to the
point where you have a tile
processor with scalar operand
network that allows you to do
communication with a very low
cost. And it might be the case
in the future that these chips
will especially be--
more complex architectures will
sit on top of these so
you'll use these as fundamental
building blocks.
And there was the 80 chip
multicore from Intel: there
have been rumors that that might
actually be something
like a graphics processor that
has something like a scalar
operand network because
you could
communicate with a very fast--
with very low latency
between tiles.
And in that article which came
out a few months ago was the
first time I think that I had
seen tile architectures used
in literature or in
publications.
So I think you'll see more of
these kinds of designs pattern
appear as people scale out to
more than 2 cores, 4 cores, 8
cores and so on, where you
could still communication
reasonably well with caches.
And that's all I prepared
for today.
Any other questions?
And this is a list
of people who
contributed to the raw project.
A lot of students who are
led by Anant and Saman.
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE:
[OBSCURED]
view of what happened in our
groups and then how it relates
to necessary to what you need.
But this is trying to take
it to a much finer grain.
Whereas in Cell, of course, the
message has to be large,
you can do a lot of coarse
grain stuff.
But in raw, you try to do much
more fine grain stuff.
But we're going to talk
about it the next
lecture on the future.
[OBSCURED]
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
Don't you need long wires
for the clock.
PROFESSOR RABBAH: There's
no global clock.
AUDIENCE: So you have this
network that seems to --
So that the network actually
requires handshaking?
Or--
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE: The way
you can do is, you can in
modern processors, [OBSCURED]
so since there's no long wire,
you can actually carry the
clock with the data.
So in the global world, the
switching here would happen
when the switching here.
But since there's no big wire
connecting, then that's OK.
So you can deal with
clock ticking.
AUDIENCE: So this is
not going to be
not clock drift because--
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE: Yeah,
that's clock drift.
One end of the process clock
is happening at the global
instant time at the other
end of the processor.
And since the wires also kind
of go in the tree, you can
deal with that.
AUDIENCE: Drift meaning
ticking at
different rates, not just--
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE:
Yeah, I know.
Basically I don't think
I can go back to it.
It has a skew.
There's a clock skew going
in between those.
AUDIENCE: So you don't need
synchronizers between the
different tiles?
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE: No, we
don't need synchronizers
because tiles are local.
The clock would bring
those tiles.
The clock would bring two things
that communicate close
enough that it fits
it in the cycle.
But for example, if you get it
two very far away branches of
a tree and then if you try to
communicate with them then you
have a problem.
Another thing is when the tree
goes here, you want to use two
different branches it's
similar to going down.
So you can compress
the process.
So there are all these things.
I mean, modern processors
really really destable.
The problem occurs when you try
to connect directly from
the far end of the branch to
something that gets clocked
there to something that
clocks at a very
early end of the branch.
If you're trying to connect
those two, then the skew might
be too long.
Then you can get into
clock trouble.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
I was just worried about
this local network.
[OBSCURED]
AUDIENCE: Another question I had
was in the mesh, obviously
the processors in the middle
have further to get to the I/O
devices or to the main memory.
What do you see happening as you
get to larger and larger
processors?
Are they going to just put more
and more local memory on
the tile and [OBSCURED]
it, or are they going to add
extra memory buses on it?
PROFESSOR RABBAH: It could
be a combination of both.
So it's not just memory,
I/O devices.
If you're doing I/O then you
might to be placed at a part
of the chip that has direct
access to an I/O device or
very close.
It also comes up in the case
of the communication
orchestration.
So if this guy is doing the
branch then you want him
essentially centrally located.
So the best patterns for
allocating things is
essentially across.
It's like a plus sign where
it branches in the middle.
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE: But
that's not [OBSCURED].
You can make them uniform by
everybody equally there.
And a lot of times people have
done that simple model with
everybody equally there Or you
try to take advantage of
closeness and stuff like that.
So you can't have both ways.
So anytime you try to
make me [OBSCURED]
very, very close and fast
access, you're are doing it by
basically making the other parts
to have less resources
and less access.
On the other hand, there are
a lot of people working on
[INAUDIBLE]
things that, for example,
there's a thing called tree
space laser.
So what that does is you put a
mirror on top of the tile, on
top of the processor.
And each of these-- you can
embed a small LED transmitter
into the chip.
So basically if you want to
communicate with someone, you
just bounce that laser on
top of that and get it
to the right guy.
So there are a lot of exotic
things that might be able to
solve this thing, technological
problem.
But in some case,
speed of light--
I don't think an engineer
has figured out how to
break speed of light.
Unless, of course, people go
with quantum computing and
stuff like that.
So, I mean the key thing is, you
have resources, you have
certain data and you just
have to deal with it.
Getting nice uniformity
has a cost.
PROFESSOR RABBAH: Yeah, I
mean, on the [OBSCURED]
that are groups here at MIT
who are working on optical
networks in the third
dimension.
So you have a tile chip plus
an optical network in the
third dimension which allows
you to do things like
broadcast much more
efficiently.
OK?
PROFESSOR AMARASINGHE: I guess
we'll take a break here and
take a small, three-minute break
and then we can go on to
the next topic.